I gotta like you kissed him on the lips
well forgives amis
Jason Smith and Michael carter-williams
leaves the bench now to Frazier's upset
we're talking about kissing and touchy
feeling
we've got some angry players
[Applause]
it happens here Carter Williams gets
tangled up Smith
if he thought Smith stepped over him
walked over him as he fell down then Tim
Frazier says a little frustration from
didn't take another rotation to gain
Scott Brooks can pick who he wants to
shoot the free throw and he chooses
Dwight Howard which
I'm sure quite happy to get an extra
point but to me this is kind of thumbing
your nose of a veteran player absolutely
vision game you'll see the Wizards again
[Applause]
Dwight Howard's been in this league a
long time he'll be in the Hall of Fame
eventually and ask him come off the
bench in the fourth quarter when he's
done for the night
knows that a great cook this
to meanness
and I'll shoot romantic a analytic that
when the game is pretty much decided I
mean you've waved the white flag with
the guys that you have in the game puts
in phrasing the game these general dan
throws they give them a little message
thank you very much